LSD, also known as Acid, is a psychoactive substance known for the perception and induction of hallucinations
But how it really works, how it affects our body and especially, our brain.
Lysergic acid diethylamide was first synthesized in 1938 from a mushroom that grows on rice.
in 1943, the discoverer Adolf Hofman mistakenly got some LSD in his mouth, went down and became the first person to discover the psychoactive effects of LSD
Drug research was conducted in the 1950s and 1960s, but as recreational drug use expanded, psychoactive substances were recognized as illegal in the US and research stopped.
while other drugs are dosed in grams one dose of LSD is measured at hundreds of thousands of grams, which is about a tenth of the weight of a grain of sand.
LSD affects several brain receptors such as dopamine, adrenergic and glutamic receptors.
But most research is focused on the stimulating serotonin receptor 5H2TA.
LSD connects to this receptor at an unexpected angle that leads to receptor overlap and formation of a burst.
LSD is trapped like this, causing the receptor to re-trigger which leads to hallucinations.
The response of our body is to withdraw the 5H2TA receptor back into the cell in order to destroy LSD but this can take up to 12 hours, which is why the condition can last for so long.
Recently, LSD research has experienced a return and, using neuro projection techniques, scientists have found that the drug causes unique communication of certain parts of the brain, mainly in the visual part of the brain.
This may explain the lively and complex hallucinations
Also, a reduced blood flow in the brain has been found, leading to major changes in consciousness described as "dissolving the ego", a state in which the boundaries between "you" and "others" disappear.
Many people describe this feeling as a way of reuniting with them themselves and with the outside world.
Study with 20 volunteers receiving 75 micrograms of LSD for 2 weeks found an increased level of optimism and openness with a growing creativity and imagination
this has led to the possible use of LSD as a therapeutic drug for patients with lethal anxiety and life-threatening diseases.
Scientists have found that after 12 months of use, panients have reported a reduced level of anxiety and improved quality of life due to the re-structuring of their lives
that's why the "microdosing" trend has caught on
A person takes a 1/10 recreational dose of drug to skip hallucinatory conditions and instead increases attention, energy and creativity
although LSD is not addictive and scientists rate it as less dangerous as cocaine or heroin, there is still a lack of more studies to understand "microdosing"
and even experienced LSD users can sometimes experience it. bad trip leading to illogical fear of paranoia and panic
LSD can also cause "flashbacks" when months after the dorga has been used suddenly, its states will reoccur.
In some extreme cases, people have developed HPPD (a persistent hallucinatory syndrome) which is like a never-ending trip
That the use of LSD leads to psychosis and suicide has been long overlooked
40% of participants in the US State Survey who have taken LSD have no increased risk of psychosis, depression or suicide attempts
But research on the positive effects of using LSD is still in its infancy, so everything is not yet clear about dorgy.
Translated, because Mary can't speak English